-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
Alright!
That's great to hear.
Let's get to the news.
President Biden is set
to make his first address
to a joint session
of Congress tomorrow.
And, just a piece
of advice, Joe --
no matter how nervous you are,
do not picture that crowd naked.
President Biden's first addres
to a joint session
of Congress tomorrow
will limit attendees,
due to the coronavirus pandemic.
Though, for what it's worth,
Congress hasn't had
a ton of success
limiting attendees lately.
President Biden today announce
new guidance
for wearing masks outdoors
And good news for everybod
on my commute -- it's this
[ Laughter ]
The Census Bureau
announced yesterday
that the official
U.S. population is 331,449,281
that I know of.
[ Laughter ]
Can we tell our writers no
to write in "wink"
[ Laughter ]
as a stage direction?
It's very creepy.
Goldich, by the way.
Yeah, Goldich.
Call him up.
House Republican Conferenc
Chair Liz Cheney said,
in a new interview,
that she is not ruling out
running for president in 2024.
I don't know.
Is America really ready
for another President Cheney
Former Republican
Congressman Doug Collins
announced yesterday
that he will not run
for a Georgia Senate seat
in 2022,
but only because Georgia
is phasing out elections.
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
announced yesterday
that the state fair will reope
this summer, at 50% capacity
And this is surprising --
he's still planning
to have his kissing booth.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Cuomo ] It's no big deal.
It's who I am.
[ Laughter ]
It's what I do.
According to reports,
fewer people watched
Sunday night's Academy Award
ceremony than ever before.
"Thank God,"
said Dan Kaluuya's mom.
[ Laughter ]
A Florida family
was recently charged with frau
in federal court
for allegedly selling bottle
of bleach that they claime
were a miracle cure
for the coronavirus,
while another Florida family
was almost reelected for it.
According to a new study,
handwashing rates have falle
to pre-pandemic levels.
At this point, most people
don't even get to "birthday.
♪♪ Happy ♪♪
Okay, whatever, all clean.
[ Laughter ]
Residents of a Texas town
last week reported seeing
a tornado
and a rainbow appear
at the same time.
Unfortunately,
no one could follow up
with any of the residents
because they were
immediately raptured.
[ Laughter ]
Chincoteague Island in Virgini
has canceled
its annual pony swim
for the second year in a row
due to the coronavirus pandemic.
They checked all
the participants for symptom
and one of them was
a little horse. ["hoarse"]
[ Laughter ]
[ As Johnny Carson ]
A little horse.
[ Laughter ]
Goldich won me back.
I was mad about the wink joke,
but, uh.
[ As Carson ]
Did you hear that, Ed?
[ Laughter ]
They checked the ponies.
A little horse.
[ Laughter ]
Officials in Indonesia
are looking for two tourists
who allegedly made
a pornographic video
on a sacred volcano,
which means it's time
for "Interactive Mono Joke!"
[ Upbeat funk plays ]
[ Laughs ]
♪♪♪♪
If you want to hear the punc
line, "Sounds hot," press 1.
[ DJ voice ]
If you want to hear
the punch line,
"They're probably used to some
burning down there," press 2
If you want to hear
the punch line,
"They were lavas," ["lovers"
press 3.
Okay.
Let's see what you picked.
You picked...
[ Laughter ]
Thanks for playing, everyone
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughs ]
And, finally,
Tampa Bay Buccaneers
star Rob Gronkowski
set a world record
over the weekend
by catching a football dropped
from a helicopter
over 600 feet in the air.
Though, I thought
it was way more impressive
that he caught the helicopter.
[ Laughter ]
[ Tarzan voice ]
Gronk have new bird!
"No.
No, Gronk, that's not a bird!"
Bird have people inside it
That was a monologue,
everybody.